know what it is it's the big step of the
way I don't flex it to see you can check
me out on a bootleg cab podcast
bootleg cab show special guest in here
my guy to see what's the word bro new
song coming out Friday yes sir I see you
uh promoting the [ __ ] out of this new
record you were with the einer banks
which is like you know always a big deal
you pull out the guy with the ukulele
yeah yeah yeah he won guitar on me this
time you got the prosthetic hearts and
stuff yeah man yeah yeah fake hearts and
all that type of [ __ ] like that
um
albums coming this is the setup for the
album you've been putting out singles
yeah this is more so like a setup for
the EP okay so it's an EP because you
have what does that same shot Body Work
2020
20 21 so last year last year but it
wasn't like it wasn't no
it wasn't an album I haven't dropped the
album like ever ever so we're
considering everything mixtapes
everything in the label size that's
important yeah right because they want
to be like now you always out those are
mixtapes yeah yeah so I got like I got
like three mixtapes out listen man uh
I'm super proud of you yeah I saw you
post today uh some of like the gist
progression in the live shows you've
been doing I remember when you first
signed you came up to the station and I
feel like you were getting like all
these like baby comparisons which didn't
make any sense because you guys want to
make the same kind of music but like you
guys are on the same label and you know
some people say you might look like his
little brother yeah right
um but like you carved out your own lane
I feel like um I feel like you kind of
had your own genre of like what you do
yeah I feel like that's that's kind of
like you know the fight with everything
right now like the fight with everything
right now it's kind of like um
standing out yeah standing out in who I
am as an artist you know like you got
you know people from my label wanting
wanting me to be like one thing and then
you got my fans who perceive me as you
know another and what my fans perceive
me is you know that's why I truly am
so like and what is that
um
the lover boy yeah I feel like if you
want to hear about some love [ __ ] or
some heartbreak [ __ ] your music is where
you go yeah man I mean I'm a lover boy
you know I mean I I ain't perfect but
I'm the loving boy though yeah I mean
but the fans look at me like that way
yeah you know that's why I truly am but
you know they've got people at the label
who want me to you know they see the
tattoos the the grills they they know my
background they know what I come from
and they want me to be like well you
you've been through this you did this
you
all right but I'm not that though do you
feel like you're getting pressured from
the label to do different [ __ ] oh
yeah somewhat yeah I mean is that
frustrating nah because I had I had to
get to a point where it's like you know
um
I kind of like just stepped away from
that yeah held up started recording uh
for myself
and now we just present it to him when
it's ready I feel like
if you were to do
more of what everyone else is doing
right it wouldn't be as special no like
we don't need another NBA young boy no
and no disrespect to him we don't need
like we like we like I feel like we need
more music about relationships and
emotions and love I feel like that's
what's missing yeah I mean and that's
what that's was I think that's kind of
like what's special about you know
um what what I'm doing I mean because
there's not a lot of artists that
everybody want to be tough nowadays you
know I'm not saying that you know the
artist now you're super vulnerable on
records you're very like I just feel
like like I feel like you're feeling a
void man I feel like you know I know
Diddy I mean and listen you kind of do
like a
of hybrid hip-hop r b thing like yeah I
wouldn't put you in any box like a mix
but I feel like that's what's missing
like I feel like you know
there's very few artists we're getting
that from and I feel like the way you
deliver it is what makes it the most
unique you know not almost death most
deaf I mean it's
I don't know bro it's it's
I'm definitely a once in a lifetime
thing like it's it's not it'd never be
another artist like me um it'll never be
another artist that's willing to take
the steps that I'm willing to take
that's gonna put their life I don't know
I know whether I'm gonna put my life on
the line it'd just never be another
artist like me but it it'll be somebody
close to me probably I saw uh what's the
biggest uh venue we've done so far by
yourself like like biggest venue out
there by myself oh and this Android just
be listening bro
what was the I don't know man I think
like by myself
probably not not four or five thousand
not that big yeah like four like four
thousand that's a big deal yeah like
four thousand that's a big deal I mean
it's four thousand is a big deal
um that's a big deal yeah it is but I
mean
I mean I don't know it's a blessing
though bro you're like one album away
from doing an Amphitheater yeah like and
that's the crap man bro if I could tell
you so much stuff that I could tell you
like you'll be like okay yeah no it's
coming but like
you gonna see though in in the next like
in the next month by that by the
beginning of next month so the stuff big
stuff when we get over here for the EP
no not period just period for the top of
next year
features tour of like what are we
talking about both
so tell me about the song with Drake
that's coming yeah
man listen Hey listen tell them to tell
man Drake need to get in contact with me
I'm sure he already has it's coming at
the top of the Year nah I wish I would
like you know what's so crazy though bro
I'm I'm like the artist that I never
really I don't really talk to a lot of
artists I've noticed that about you I
feel like you are kind of like a you're
kind of like on an island yeah bro like
I don't see you doing like a lot of
collabs like yeah you're just kind of
doing your thing man I only do features
bro cause my label like tell me that we
need to go get features and do features
and it's like all right cool but like I
really don't care for features bro I
don't that [ __ ] don't be I don't look
for it to be genuine or I don't look to
build no relationship but like you know
people only gonna call and want features
from you when they need you you know are
you actual because listen like you said
right like in music
we'll see people do records together
yeah and they might not have ever even
have met no or let alone like know each
other like
um are there any other artists that you
would consider actual friends yeah yeah
like um
it's a few like glott great guy
Glock dirt
um who else
I rock with Osiris That's My Boy nice oh
does he owe you any money nah
nah crazy nah nah nah he don't he don't
and he's he's super nice you might have
asked me a week ago
he said no he just squared up with me a
week ago no that was my boy though like
I'm talking about like real friends he
might have a gambling problem though
yeah me too though bro oh you do yeah
bro I got a real casino gambling or
Sports gambling he got like a different
game
yeah I feel like he I feel like he I
feel like I always see him at the gimbal
anything
I mean shout out to him I met him and
his dad and they were like I haven't I
haven't interviewed him in a while but I
remember the first time he came to the
station he had his pops with him yeah
and I didn't even know he was from
Jacksonville but I saw his dad and I was
like yo you're from Florida aren't you
because I used to live in Florida so I
know what a Florida [ __ ] was
yeah
so you're you have a gambling issue I
got a real gambling problem would you
say uh well first of all what is the
go-to if you go to the casino oh I gotta
go to baccarat bro that's an old person
what James Bond how do you I don't even
know how to play that yeah yeah how does
that how do you play I don't lie bro uh
that's some senior citizenships man
you'd be playing next to people with
like their oxygen tank and [ __ ] nah I'll
be next to the Asians the Asians love
that [ __ ] Asians love it bro yeah like
but I wanna I play it like an Asian
though like what's that mean I'm great
you're really good oh great yeah hey
Asians love to gamble right you go to
that high limit room there's a bunch of
Asians in that [ __ ] where I'm at
baby yeah you you want to find me come
find me in the high limit room like I'm
I'm near like some cigarettes like I
won't lie all right I never I never even
I never told nobody this like uh you've
seen the video with when baby just uh
you seen the video when baby just won
like a million dollars at the casino I
think he was playing baccarat
um
I did that like a couple months ago you
made a million dollars yeah I mean like
I probably made like 1.9 million dollars
bro
okay so that sounds amazing
you're gonna show me yeah I already knew
it and for anybody who gambles that
sounds great but that also means
I took like 45 000. okay okay because
I'm just trying to figure out all right
are you are you up or are you even
because yeah yeah you might have you
might have got mine one there right it's
like it's like you might have won that
but yeah but over the totality of your
gambling career I don't keep going like
that now would you say you're closer to
even are you up or you down because 1.9
million that's a big hit yeah I'm I'm
alive I'm close to the even though bro
cause I gamble you gotta think you you
go spend money you're closer to even
yeah you will spend money and then you
go back and then you lose money yeah do
they know you like when you go you get
like the VIP treatment they'd be like
here you have a room sir yeah
I get like a I got I got like yeah I get
penthouses and all that
not and not because you're a famous
artist no because because you're
spending money with them yeah they want
you to stay yeah they want me to stay
they give you all the free food you're
asking for all damn that's serious I was
gonna say can I see my camera roll my
camera roll crazy no no no no we don't
want to see he's not getting whatever no
I'm gonna take it let's see what camera
roll bro what's the angle here because
there's a lot of word I had to look back
at the camera all right what is the
video nobody wants to scroll too far
don't accidentally show me something I
don't want to see you no man I don't
need to see how much of a lover boy you
are no no no you don't need to see that
show me the [ __ ] gambling the
gambling video or picture 1.9 million is
crazy I play craps I play roulette you
play craps and roulette I can't I don't
know what background I'm not going to
Vegas tomorrow though so maybe I'll try
it out I'll go hang out you're going to
Vegas forever tomorrow yeah I'm gonna go
hang out with some Asians and be like yo
my friends homie I should be playing
this game with y'all that's the game bro
I'm gonna bring some Marlboros I'm gonna
get them from Neil from your label is
there gonna go smoke and gamble with
some Asians try to win 1.9 million you
went you won that off of 45k yes sir
45
000. where is this IR hold on we're
getting close and what what state is
this in Vegas or is this yeah in Vegas
oh yeah you lit like once you just move
to Vegas okay here we go here we go
here we go nope a lot
why don't I move to Vegas Vegas is crazy
bro no state tax yeah no state tax so
that's the that's the that's the crazy
part bro let me and then we gonna and
then we gonna but the crazy part is
right
I didn't I didn't know that okay
um I didn't know that with table games
it's no text yeah right
so I won the money
they asked me did I want
a jet to go home
I don't fly with private jets I still
get on Commercial fronts right ask me
did I want a jet the jet like forty
thousand dollars I just [ __ ] wanted
1.9 million yeah [ __ ] it's nothing yeah
yo bro I said no because I was scared
I'm like yo nah it's some freaky [ __ ]
going on I just want all this money from
them like they're trying to [ __ ]
they're gonna disappear you or something
they're trying to get me like what's the
name of that [ __ ] uh TV show where
the [ __ ] plane flew back in time lost
bro whatever the [ __ ] the name oh oh no
no uh manifest manifest yeah bro they
trying to [ __ ] manifest me yeah maybe
so I'm like nah like I'm not I'm not I'm
cool I'm cool on the flights which
casino is this this is uh this uh so I
won at the cosmo great casino by the way
tons of hookers past 12. right I wanted
the cosmo and then you know [ __ ] the
cosmo up I'm actually being from there
that's another thing as you would be
yeah because you won you took two
million dollars from that [ __ ] bear
me so boom right
I'm like no I'm cool blah blah whatever
the case may be I [ __ ] put the money
in my bank account and fly home
bro I gotta [ __ ] pay taxes on that
[ __ ] now because I put it in my bank
account you should have just took the
cash and been like I'm gonna live off of
this cash for the rest of the year I put
it in my bank account and I gotta pay
taxes on it bro and that's like half
crazy story how much how much is that
about that's like half right uh close to
it yeah
look at that that's one of the videos
oh my God they gave you all that cash
and you put it in the bank
I'm gonna gamble with you
let's do it and that's not even all of
it bro that's like 800 that's like 800
of it right there
yeah yeah how'd you get banned from the
cosmo
oh um
so I'm may or may not have had a firearm
uh yeah let's just say you may not have
had one may not have had one um you
can't have one there
you got to tell them before you come in
oh I mean you know there was that
shooting in Vegas I didn't know that
though I'm I'm [ __ ] 22 bro you know
there was like a guy in a room shooting
people like yeah like [ __ ] I ain't no I
didn't know none of that so they found
out you had a gun when they found out
and they seen it allegedly allegedly and
they seen it it was like and then when
they told me what happened I'm like uh
okay like I get that like yeah I get
that I get why y'all babe but I'm I'm
licensed though this is uh is this is
this the night you ran into ddg in Vegas
yeah it is it's that same night yeah it
is are you guys okay now
nah bro he was just here yesterday he's
such a nice guy and you're such a nice
guy bro
I'm Gonna Keep It on here oh wow I was
gonna say I don't know why he got a
problem with me but yeah I mean I know
why but why is it did you [ __ ] Ruby Rose
no I didn't like I don't know I always
assumed you smashed Ruby Rose or
something man man Ruby man Ruby was cool
if you ever make out with her nah
nothing I want a lot of just subscribe
to her only fans
[Music]
what the [ __ ] that [ __ ] let's go to
Reddit it's free yeah
what is Reddit
I have no idea I have no idea you know
because why do you know that
I have no idea all right so here's the
thing right with him know
I don't I don't know I I never really
because supposedly where you guys ran
into each other was Vegas right yeah
yeah but well it's that [ __ ] like him
well I don't got no problem to really
had I don't have no reason to really
have a problem I feel like if you guys
hung out together you guys would get
along because he's a really nice guy
you're a really nice guy he's a very
smart guy you're a very smart guy you're
two different people though kind of
quite I mean look I mean but maybe
you're not you don't know I mean I would
I wouldn't even say that I wouldn't no I
ain't even gonna say we two different
people because we haven't been around
each other but like I don't know bro I
really don't man is it all about a girl
though is that what the kind of because
I feel like most issues I really don't I
don't care they had no friends in this
[ __ ] but I ain't got no problem so if
any sort of any if any like well artists
really don't like me all that should be
over a girl like and that [ __ ] ain't
nothing what up y'all we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our new
sponsors our family at hardeen Las Vegas
you see what it is you see what it is
welcome to to the family hard Dean man
we're so excited I've been going to
Harding for so many years for people who
don't know Hardin is that premium
cannabis dispensary the number one
award-winning dispensary in Las Vegas
I'm talking the biggest and best
selection of cannabis products and of
course in Vegas but I'm talking about
worldwide they're them [ __ ] all
right so what you got to do is pull up
when you're in Vegas to hardine go to
Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot them
that follow on Instagram go see them
tell them I sent you when you go to
check out be like yo bootleg Kev sent me
I saw y'all talking about it on a
bootleg cat podcast look when you're in
Vegas they'll also deliver right to your
room whatever you need all right make
sure you follow the crew Harding
underscore loss Vegas go to
hardinlasvegas.com that's
j-a-r-d-i-n
lasvegas.com and don't forget when you
go to Vegas you go to Jardin tell them I
sent you and then only might throw a
little extra little eighth in the bag or
something discount the bootleg discount
you know what I'm saying get them
backwards too they give me a Packwood
the other day that geez I'm still
recovering from that [ __ ] blew my whole
[ __ ] face off in the best way Hardy
in Las Vegas all right shout out to them
let's get back to the interview I do
think the last time you came on the show
you pretty pretty blatantly it was like
I'll [ __ ] your girl yeah I did like if
you're out there
and I meet your girl I'll [ __ ] her yeah
yeah yeah
no yeah I was that was like two years
ago yeah I'm a different person better I
was like yo I'll [ __ ] your girl yeah I'm
a different person now bro and you were
talking to anyone specifically you were
just talking to the world yeah like
period though like what's going like I
want Lotto like two years ago okay like
before I got in a relationship bro like
what was gonna stop a [ __ ] from [ __ ]
my girl nothing
wait a minute wait a minute what was
going to stop somebody from [ __ ]
[ __ ] my girl if I had a girl like at
the time right what was gonna or even my
girl right now what's gonna stop him
from [ __ ] her
her love for you if she wanna [ __ ] them
no hmm they gonna [ __ ] her
so if you're a girl yeah
if your girl once so if your girl want
to [ __ ] me right what's gonna stop me
there's nothing that's gonna stop her
from doing it or vice versa what was
gonna stop me but
do you draw like old twosie with old
Tuesday would he draw the line if it was
a Married Girl or is it [ __ ] it's free
for all marriage ring your husband can
be a overseas it's not Afghanistan is
that like a sin I don't know I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm atheist so I
don't care about none of that [ __ ] I
don't care sin no sin whatever what are
we talking about
but would you have like a coat of
conduct or be like you know what you're
married
or that make it even better because then
because then if it's a merry girl you're
[ __ ] with you know for sure she don't
want it to get out so it's a lot less
sloppy no ethically it's a little more
[ __ ] up but even even if you was
married I was it was it was taxing you
were you were you were taking down the
married yeah bro I didn't care bro you
didn't care nice living life breathing
air not playing Fair
what's the oldest chick you've hooked up
with like probably like 43. nice
cougar Vibes yeah I was young what about
that what's the heaviest Queen you've
poached oh my God oh I'm not that heavy
though not that heavy
north of lizzo
I was trying to see have you dabbled
into bb dubs man
oh my God you know Drake loves BBWs and
you know I've always heard like uh girls
who are certain I think of certain uh
stature that they're they're talented in
ways that this is actually a great
performer by the way oh my God lizzo's
[ __ ] an alien when it comes to just
Talent yeah she's a great performer and
and musically she's incredible like
she's so fire I I just I'm just saying I
do know that South though in in my
smaller okay because I know like the
heavier usually they got them in my
experience the mouse game is usually a
lot more uh in my experience it's crazy
it's like usually I'm obviously married
now I'm in a relationship but prior to
that you know yeah yeah right so you're
in a relationship yeah how long has this
been a
oh
prison time for some time now not that
long not that long what what about your
lady because I feel like you're the kind
of guy who I wouldn't expect to be in a
relationship yeah so what about your
lady was like yo this girl's I want to
make this you know I want to put a title
on this you know what's so crazy though
bro because you are the lover boy yeah I
am
but that's why I tried I try not to like
our relationship I like I used to have
our relationship like so broad on the
internet like I remember seeing that it
used to be everywhere I stopped posting
it though right just because simply I
wanted to keep it away from the world
like they're smart
what's going on bro right
because like then you end up in a
situation like shout out to my guy in La
Chapa or like he breaks up with this
girl and then he has to explain what
happened because yeah they're on the
internet together so much right and it's
like
don't know why I really know what's
going on what's going on but you got so
many people in your business that you
feel like you just gotta you got to feel
like you owe it to the like crap like
you know I mean because then it's like
and what's and it's not sacred anymore
it really is so like I don't know I try
to keep that away from the world because
you know I mean they started paying uh
painting image of y'all relationship
like it's perfect and no relationship is
perfect we're not [ __ ] perfect like
we ain't nowhere close to perfect
and we ain't we not just gonna act like
I'm just Prince Charming or like I'm
just so like I try to keep that [ __ ]
away from the world because what we got
going on people don't know about you
know I mean so
I do like the uh I'd like to lie in the
annalize pushing like let me cheat in
peace that was a very like
I'm sure a lot of men in the world
appreciate him saying that publicly and
they're probably looking at their ladies
like see
just in peace no I'm not one of those
men because I'm I'm happily married I
love my wife my wife did you say that
though yes he said she wouldn't let me
cheat in peace
what
he had this whole video explanation he
was like she knows what she signed up
for she wouldn't let me do my thing on
the side in peace anymore
wait I don't know bro I mean I respected
yeah he's you know shop is doing a lot
of wild [ __ ] semen retention you know
he's drinking all kinds of [ __ ]
lotions and potions and [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying he's young as [ __ ] he's
like 18 going on 40 though when you talk
to him I'm like bro you got wisdom how
do you know about all these rude herbs
and roots and all kinds of yeah smart as
hell yoga and [ __ ] yeah I [ __ ] with him
though yeah great guy super nice kid we
uh we played in uh we played in what's
the name of this
yeah and like my whole like my whole
thing was just to hate on them to hate
you hate on them so bad yeah when you
when you see the new season of the
cruelly oh my [ __ ] god were you
guarding him
nah I didn't even play oh you didn't
play I just was hosting oh you were
hosting this one because we lost the
last one were you hosting with nems yeah
yeah how's the [ __ ] life being wrong
Bing Bong I was talking so much [ __ ]
though I bet you were I said I [ __ ]
hate job oh he [ __ ] sucks
yeah I said someone you see this [ __ ]
where I say he eat grass you guys yeah I
said I said they asked they asked what
what I thought about him I said he I say
I just eat burgers and he eat grass
and like it was like this whole thing on
social media but I wasn't joking I was
serious though and in the world like
took it and they like just like what I
don't know though you know it was just
like my thing to hate on them you know I
mean I [ __ ] when they come to
basketball I hate them
because he got so much energy he's got a
lot of energy you want to run around the
court I mean you hear his music he's
just like I got asthma bro yeah no me
too man I'm not chasing you around the
court and [ __ ] like that so no did you
play at sports like in high school yeah
I was nice though basketball basketball
football baseball I feel like in the
South football is like religion like
like high school football
so when I moved down south like when I
moved down south from originally from up
in New York right yeah Upstate um
Rochester nah Syracuse Syracuse the
Orangemen yeah Rochester and Syracuse
not that different though yeah it's like
the same place two different cities
though I heard Rochester is [ __ ]
grimy oh yeah Syracuse like that I've
been to Buffalo Buffalo was wild yes
Buffalo was like Detroit with hot wings
oh yeah I actually think Detroit's nicer
than Buffalo no come to Syracuse I mean
sure I'd like I wouldn't mind going and
watching um
one of those nights when they have like
a Carmelo Anthony bobble head an orange
uh yeah a Syracuse game I'll show up
yeah what's the name of that coach uh
Jim behind yeah is he still coaching God
damn he's been coaching since I was a
baby he didn't go to since I was [ __ ]
before I was born
[ __ ] crazy yeah I think he's still
but I think he's still cool would you
consider yourself someone who reps
Carolina or Syracuse
Chapel Hill North Carolina UNC UNC yeah
yeah Caleb love yeah I think uh you know
that's the best player in college
basketball is he yeah he [ __ ] he
can't nobody I feel like I don't start
paying attention to college basketball
and everybody [ __ ] sucks I compared
to Caleb once March Madness comes we'll
start paying attention unless [ __ ]
[ __ ] basketball player in the world I
wasn't saying unless there's like like
the Zion season I watched I watched Zion
I'm a John Maria fan too yeah job was a
beast yeah [ __ ] native [ __ ]
basketball player in the world
I also feel like he kind of wants to be
a rapper which which might not be a good
thing yeah he don't really want to be a
rapper he more so like he just he's
having his way he's like the NBA young
boy of the NBA he'd be on Twitter saying
no why I'm like bro put your phone down
nah [ __ ] that live life
when he said that [ __ ] like you got to
come to the treasures and then the
picture popped up with him as a kid like
with his parents
[Music]
he from the Carolina you're not signed
to CMG I know you played it my boy my
boy from the Carolinas too that's that
that's that Carolina and that boy your
job's probably the best the top three
watch in the league if you just like
have League Pass just watching him I
can't even watching basketball before
really [ __ ] job Marine fan he's a
beast man I'll [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] and
then you got guys like the Charlotte
Hornet yeah Mr bridges yeah I was I was
I was um who who obviously wants to be a
rapper so bad
yo damn that all right so so he signed
the Sada baby no no oh he make music
miles bridges yeah signed oh I didn't
know that I just signed to he's richer
than almost every rapper and he signed
to Sada baby Sada baby's my guy yeah but
I'm like
you sign you you could just bankroll and
then he's posting cups of lean lemonade
is lemonade
with Blunts and [ __ ] I'm like bro you
got no blunts man you're heading into
the biggest off-season of your career
miles Bridges like that though I mean
clearly he's also like like that I like
that right now
wait is he yeah no one signed him
because we had a domestic violence
situation that was pretty bad so ah he
was about to get probably 180 million
dollars
and [ __ ] it off he got a sick but I
hope so but he's gonna shake back for a
[ __ ] vets minimum yeah I'm praying
for him yeah me too man yeah I mean but
are you a Hornets fan even if you do
that nah but but man I just don't oh man
I don't be like it I don't like to see
[ __ ] go down nobody does for sure it's
just it's just unfortunate because
you're like yo you had you were due for
a big contract yeah bro like I mean that
[ __ ] he got it I don't like seeing that
[ __ ] bro he would be straight he heard
yesterday that's the name so you're not
a Hornets fan no I know on this fan no
yeah I know I don't know more of a
Grizzly fan yeah I'm a great I'm a job
you're a player player guy I'm a job
Caleb love UNC UNC how much you hate
Duke I [ __ ] hate Duke yeah I [ __ ]
hate him I'm glad they broke the uh
stereotype of dude awkward white guys
yeah
yeah nuke sucks they've gotten rid of
awkward white guys recently which I
appreciate you know they had they had
the RJ Barrett uh Zion season yeah Duke
[ __ ] sucks yeah yeah I [ __ ] hate
Duke so bad when I think of uh yeah male
Cairns I think of Duke Blue Devils yeah
they [ __ ] suck oh what's that one
dude's name that's on the grizzly like
to be a Duke fan
certain kind of people are Duke fans
yeah certain kind of people but to be a
UNC Chapel Hill fan that's I mean I had
I grew up
um like in North Carolina because Jordan
played there yeah that's a real Pride
Vince Vince Carter was there Antoine
Jameson was here
who else was though Brandon Haywood yes
sir yeah so you're more of a college guy
yeah I'm more of a Caleb love guy Caleb
love Do you have do you do you like a
small homie oh that's just your boy it's
my boy nice are you managing him it
sounds like you are I God damn near you
need to bro he's like yo Caleb love I
just started a sports agency and yo he's
my first client yo I swear to God like
if I could [ __ ] sign them you
wouldn't
I mean listen it's not outside of the
room if you start rapping like if you
start rapping like miles
tell him not to do that all right all
right so if you care about Caleb love
tell him not to start rapping I'll make
sure he won't start rapping but and
Miles was not a bad rapper decent music
yeah it was kind of like what I like
about Caleb dohe humble that's good he's
too humble bro
he too he too if I was hit if I was yo
if I was in the NBA I'll probably be
like John Moran bro
just talking on fools not like not even
that like just I mean on Twitter popping
off you know what I'm saying some wow I
can't [ __ ] guard me yeah why why what
are we talking about I dunk on you like
I will literally dunk on you I've dunked
on half of the [ __ ] League this is
what are we talking about this is true
man
um for you now that uh you're obviously
winning 1.9 million dollars on a random
night at the at the cosmo all right what
are you doing like with your money are
you I mean so I'm about to um I'm about
to really start diving into the real
estate thing nice um it's actually great
time yeah because it's about to crash
yes so just wait like nine to 12 more
months not work work because it's really
the rates are super high yeah and the
price has not corrected yet yeah once it
correct you'll be able to get a lot yeah
yeah that's smart man yeah so I'm about
to start getting real estate and then
it's just a few things I want to do with
my money like um
I got I still got a lot more money
coming in bro like that's the thing like
I got so much [ __ ] that I haven't I
ain't drop no album man I still gotta
get paid for that [ __ ] and then how many
plaques do you have right now
I only got two plaques so that's that's
the thing like when people say like you
ever go on academics and you see the
[ __ ] [ __ ] about people in the
comments like Tuesday fell off and or
artists they say artists fell off and or
any people say that about you yeah
actually I you know what's crazy is that
I feel like I don't pay attention to
that [ __ ] because in my opinion just
based on my Optics I'm like yo you're
like
bigger than ever yeah because when I
talk to people yeah they really [ __ ]
with you like I feel like yeah that's
like see that's the thing about me like
I feel like you're like like not like a
a I don't know not like me bro it's
crazy I don't do anything yeah I don't I
don't bother any I don't even go out the
house like so like you let the comments
get to you though hell no bro good
because that [ __ ] is like tired people
if people knew how I was living like
outside of like right well I'm I'm
straight like my life is good I I just
had a son I mean congratulations I'm
like it's your first baby first baby
how's that changing you man just
a lot of the things that I used to do
and the things that I used to be into I
ain't into no more like I mean just
negative [ __ ] I ain't I don't live for
the negative I live for the positive
that's smart man I feel like once you
can like I mean we've all been young
we've all been [ __ ] through our turn
stage where we take everything personal
where we're always like I feel like once
you get past that [ __ ] it's like when
you really start leveling up your whole
life yeah bro you stop letting little
[ __ ] dictate how your day goes yeah bro
so like the young [ __ ] bro I'm kind of
past the young [ __ ] like that's why the
[ __ ] like bro even with ddg like it's
like
yeah well there's a couple artists that
like I'd have had that issue with like
when it comes to the girls like and
whatever the issue was like I mean bro
we'll look back at this [ __ ] 20 years
from now and be like damn like uh for
what yeah what was that [ __ ] about so
like for the for the internet and all
that [ __ ] is cool it's good but in
reality like it's too much [ __ ] going on
nowhere it's people and I I'm not
fighting no body you shouldn't we have
no reason to fight it's too many people
out here dying 100 right I ain't so I
don't like with that [ __ ]
yo it's bootleg Kev here to tell you
about our partners at my bookie damn it
football season we're in the thick of it
right now I hit big last week too man I
want to give a shout out to uh to my guy
who gave me the picture out of my guy
sports book Killer but listen what you
got to do is go to my bookie right now
get in on this NFL action you know NBA
is coming up too you could bet on
anything you want they got the player
props you could do the a parlay Builder
you could bet on your favorite team to
win the Super Bowl get them odds up
whatever it is the most important thing
get that first time deposit bonus that
means when you sign up for your account
use the promo code bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g and you will get a deposit
match so if you put in 200 they're gonna
give you two hundred dollars on top of
that to gamble with for free if you put
in a thousand dollars they're gonna
match that deposit with a free thousand
dollars for you to gamble with right now
so what the [ __ ] are you waiting for
let's get this money let's watch some
[ __ ] football and let's get paid with
my bookie yeah it's like yo man like
this [ __ ] ain't worth it like like at
the end of the day
I mean like I said when I was like yo
everything I should not real beef though
to me yeah it's not because we don't
seen each other like if we really had a
real problem
no matter where we were you guys are
great guys both you guys are not like I
know I've had artists sit here that I'm
like okay that guy's probably a bad dude
someone I wouldn't want to hang out with
yeah I'm not that though bro yeah I
ain't that I'm your child it's a
difference between like Street [ __ ]
and hood [ __ ] I'm just a [ __ ] from
the hook yeah she's a good dude man get
into it put enough disposable income to
buy a giant owl chain yeah something
like that [ __ ] is [ __ ] massive yeah
you didn't have it on yeah I didn't have
this one out when I first came here the
first time either you love Hooters hot
wings
I like owls bro you love owls okay yeah
you know the owl symbolize
I don't know knowledge Temple to college
knowledge wisdom and power man shout out
to the house I like that yeah knowledge
wisdom power would you ever have a pet
owl seems like damn oh yeah seems a
little dangerous especially with the kid
you know I want a white and gray owl you
know and then with the baby yeah that
owl [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody up in there yo
you ever seen [ __ ] Harry Potter and
[ __ ] where the [ __ ] yeah but that's a
card I mean what are we talking about I
don't know yeah that's right you'll be
Harry Potter fan no I'm saying something
like that you and your lady what do you
binge watch at home what TV shows uh
well binge watch TV shows I just watch
action movies and she watch them with me
like action movies I [ __ ]
like John Wick like yo John Wick like
[ __ ]
007 like double seven are the best
especially the new ones Matrix [ __ ]
anything crazy where I feel like I could
probably do that [ __ ] yeah John Wick's
the one though I think John Wick's the
best yeah like I kind of feel like John
Wick sometimes like John Wick make me do
things that I feel like I probably
shouldn't be doing like kill people
um I'm kidding
yo the fact the fact that they killed
his dog and we got three movies out of
it yo that motherfucker's like level of
Revengers and say yo like
one dog dies we get three movies with
500 people getting murdered that's
that's how much a man loves this [ __ ]
yeah or his dog or his dog because it
was a guy right are you a dog guy it was
a boy dog right it was a dog yeah I mean
I get a dog I love my dog someone killed
my dog shout out to Lebowski yeah my
dog's name is a basket he's a little
pomeranian yeah out of all names it's
named after that movie right there The
Big Lebowski it's my favorite movie oh
okay all right yeah yeah sounds great
this pool sleeps with me and my wife
every night oh my God it's Lebowski
Lebowski his name is Jeffrey Lebowski oh
that's nice but we call him you have a
dog no I had one he died No I gave him
away because I was I was too busy on the
road that's smart yeah you don't want to
neglect a dog it was probably a Frenchie
wasn't it nah he's a pit bull oh good
yeah just a pitbull every rapper's got a
[ __ ] Frenchie it's like a [ __ ]
fashion accessory by the way I have a
friendship too oh you're not that [ __ ]
bro
so I don't follow the train my
Pomeranian is Jeff Lebowski and my
Frenchie is Larry David from Curb Your
Enthusiasm yeah you ever watched that
show nope really it's a funny show ever
it's on HBO I gotta watch it incredible
okay so you like action movies
have you watched the boys on Amazon
Prime I think so about the [ __ ] up
superheroes nope oh my god dude it's a
show about uh it's about like if super
if like like imagine like
in our real world they were superheroes
it's like about how corrupt they are and
how they'd be like [ __ ] [ __ ]
murdering people and nobody knows it's
[ __ ] crazy right maybe doing drugs
and [ __ ] and not crazy [ __ ] yeah you
know like there's like real superpowers
what is all Amazon Prime I'm gonna watch
it it's pretty crazy yeah I think you
and your lady would enjoy that what was
it uh so ep's coming
[Music]
um top it here sooner you'd be coming
away album Top of the Year album Top of
the Year already got features for the
album yeah
how do you put which eggs in which
basket this is EP music this is album
music so the name of my EP uh it'll be
out by time yeah not the EP won't be out
but by the time we dropped this
interview the song will be out the the
RP title and the artwork and stuff would
be unless we put it out in 20 minutes
yeah no I didn't I if you I'm just
kidding we'll wait we'll wait I was
gonna say if you put the [ __ ] out of 20
minutes no no no no you'll be like yo
you're talking to me your turnaround
time oh incredible yeah like nah you
know I see editing over there right now
he's not all right but no no so so so
what's the name so the name of the uh EP
is Boys Don't Cry I like that yeah so
you know how you you said like you know
I'm the vulnerable artist yeah man like
you know as as men we always start to be
tough and I mean and not have emotions
to do this do that whatever the case may
be um
it's just it's just you know leaning
into you know allowing allowing men to
be vulnerable and uh
and show that like you know I'm looked
at as the artist that make songs for the
women and [ __ ] like that which is cool
um but it's all right as men to be
vulnerable yeah it is man that's always
more songs for women there's more songs
for women it's just the whole tape for
for the [ __ ] yeah something like that
not really it's a couple songs for the
dudes but it's it's a it's just it's
allowing yourself to be vulnerable bro I
mean because at the end of the day bro
all that tough [ __ ] bro is for the birds
man like it's like it's not we don't
like [ __ ] bro
this is true
I don't like [ __ ] like I mean I know a
few guys that don't shot a little nausea
true yeah true yo my producer Cyrus
another thing though nah like what like
even though it like with nas though yeah
um
like for him to be able to take what he
did and like just take that [ __ ] by
storm that's crazy bro I think
all right first of all musically he's
incredible Vietnam most definitely I
hate when people try to act like little
Naz X don't make [ __ ] hit records now
he make hit records and then on top of
that he is on like bro and like I I I
just I hate the little nazex hate cause
I'm like yo this dude is literally
making it possible for like I don't go I
don't give a [ __ ] if you straight it
don't matter okay lesbian bisexual is
the music good yes Musical and because
it's a few it's a few it's a few gay
artists that's like in the industry bro
yeah like uh I had an interview with
Saucy Santana uh who's like very gay
well I mean not like probably any more
gay than anyone else but he's uh what
did he say he's like flamboyant right
he's more flamboyant but like yeah
um you know I I always bumping the uh in
the airport yeah I just think it's dope
that like everybody has representation
hip-hop now because before when we were
growing up it wouldn't be possible for
somebody to be a gay rapper hey what up
y'all it's bootleg Kev here to stop the
interview sorry uh but we gotta pay the
[ __ ] bills and you know not only do
we have to pay the bills but we also
gotta take care of them [ __ ] out there
that's right make sure you go to
bluetooth.com right now you know the
bootleg kept podcast we are presented by
bluetooth proudly I happen to every once
in a while dabble in a little chooski
you know what I'm saying and let me tell
you something my dick thanks me for it
every single time uh so listen if you go
to Bluetooth use the promo code bootleg
you're gonna get your first month supply
for free now we're talking the same
active ingredient as Viagra as Cialis
without the awkward doctor's appointment
visit you just go online they get you
taken care of it gets delivered right to
your [ __ ] door in discreet packaging
it's a beautiful thing and how about
this
brand new product alert on Bluetooth all
right and I'm gonna [ __ ] this up for
sure so I'm gonna try to read it uh now
Bluetooth has a mint flavored chewable
with
bardenophil which is the same active
ingredient in Levitra and stackson
so shout out to Levitra
same active ingredient in the mint
flavor chewables so what are we doing go
get you a little mint boy go get you a
little blue chew whatever the [ __ ] you
need just know
whatever young lady or man or Etc that
you're dealing with they're gonna
[ __ ] thank you for it because your
dick's going to be harder than it's ever
been in your whole [ __ ] life man it's
gonna be great and like if you're a
single guy
take a blue chew
jack off
just be a better jerk I'll tell you that
all right bluetooth.com go right now
and uh you know I know we have a lot of
male listeners who like underground raps
so chances are you're not getting a lot
of [ __ ] but I promise you one thing you
take that blue tree you're gonna beat
your dick like it stole something all
night long bluetooth.com use that promo
code bootleg right now and they will
give you the first month for free so go
do that [ __ ] do you have a name for your
fans
no we don't the lover girls the lover
boys no we don't we don't should come up
with one it's like a [ __ ] the choosy
squad or something somebody said
somebody said Tootsie Rolls ooh not
doing that though
Tootsie Roll sounds like uh your friends
would all be BBWs yeah I'm not doing
that I think of like girls with rolls
that'd be a nice uh like when your album
comes out
your label is going to send a bunch of
shitty stuff out to radio stations that
know that that they don't want right
like sometimes they'll send like here's
a t-shirt that's too small for you and
some condoms with the name of the song
on it oh yeah so they can send twozie
rolls out to program directors and
they're gonna just throw them away but
they'll post them you know yeah it'll be
cool
and it'll come out of your budget that's
what's [ __ ] up
and they'll probably be like yeah those
two zeros that was eighty thousand
dollars good luck that's it a million
two she rolls out now Doc winners got a
[ __ ] three cases of two zeros at this
[ __ ] desk yeah now I don't play that
[ __ ] though bro my budget wouldn't come
to my budget bro are you pretty on top
of your [ __ ]
I don't play none of that [ __ ]
because you know so I mean they'll spend
it without you I mean you'll be like
wait a minute what
yeah is that like because obviously you
know shout out to Arnold and uh shout
out to uh to the crew over there uh is
is it like having because Arnold's OG
Carter's a great guy having those two
guys like on your teams got to be great
especially when dealing with like the
big label because I feel like they're
very hip to just how this whole [ __ ]
works like based on their perspective
and how like they came into the game you
know what I mean right
um when it comes to Arnold light and
just
honor the label it's really it's really
like my manager because I'm with him
like every day got you you get what I'm
saying um
he kind of like put me on game
with everything that I need to know and
just taking the steps that we need we
need to take in
I mean just having me more ahead of what
the average artist would be
yeah I feel like the other thing I've
been I'm glad that you guys haven't
gone out of your way to chase radio too
hard because that shit's expensive I
know you guys like love cycle had some
[ __ ] success I remember it was like
the I Heart pick of the week and we were
playing it yeah it worked but in terms
of like sometimes man some of these
labels anytime you're an artist and you
catch any traction on any record they
want to [ __ ] impact it at radio and
that shit's like 125 000 every minimum
and it's like yo like 125 000 minimum
right and it's like yo you got to pick
and choose those times because at the
end of the day
you also want to [ __ ] make some money
off your music you don't want to be one
of those artists that has the tour to
make money because your [ __ ] budget
got blown like crazy so yeah I think
you're pretty smart with that Vietnam it
won't take much [ __ ] the radio yeah and
you're fighting you fly under the radar
while also doing like [ __ ] 50 million
views on everybody
uh who's on the EP
nobody nobody no one at all no features
you know EPS only could be six songs now
so if it's seven it's an album yeah so
six records I think seven is like an LP
LP of album that's yeah yeah
so album you're gonna bring out the big
guns yeah big ones Bazookas Drake
man listen I wish bro I'm telling you
hey did you ever see the uh OMB PC
freestyle I did yo bro if you see this
um yeah I did see that he he did
something over your beat we're in
Atlanta yeah I did yeah crazy out there
people are like yo y'all gotta drop that
as an official because that [ __ ] was
crazy that's crazy what made you pick
that beat though bro I went I was in
Atlanta with him and I was like yo let's
do a freestyle like I had like an Airbnb
but he was like just we'll just shoot it
at the studio yeah and he was like ah
this Tuesday beat I want you to I want
to do something on it and it worked he
killed it that's my [ __ ] I [ __ ] with
him good guy man good guy shout out to
Alabama yes what's your biggest market
like would you say like like if you go
to a market like where you're like yo
maybe it's the street probably like uh
Houston H-Town between you standing um
Houston it's a few places
Houston probably top three strip club
City yeah top three yeah they got this
this club out there called uh I think
like Skye
they got the clubs where you could bring
your own bottle in yeah I love I love
Houston Houston's special yeah you got
the Mexican food you got the soul food
you got everything in Houston we gotta
stop the interview tell you about our
partners at Odd Socks well first of all
let's check out the brand new collab
look at these the bootleg capsock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
going to figure out a way to give them
away though uh but look Odd Socks the
most comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been walking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an odd sock basic you
know what I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd
Socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about Nickelodeon
shout out to Patrick [ __ ]
Cheez-Its Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear yeah I
mean yeah these are the Odd Socks Basics
all right so if you go to the website
right now order you some underwear order
you some socks use the promo code
bootleg Kev that's one word altogether
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off at
checkout go to oddsoxofficial.com one
more time that's oddsocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg Kev and you will save
20 off your order of course we're
presented by Odd Socks and we are proud
to say so all right let's get back to
the interview yeah you were telling me
earlier
um you're taking the soap for people who
don't know your teeth are you have
permanent diamond teeth yeah so you're
gonna be going you're taking them out
going normal teeth regular teeth how
long have you had these teeth like two
years
more of a pain in the ass to have teeth
like that because you got to floss more
you got floss your gums to be bleeding
and [ __ ]
brush your teeth special toothpaste for
the diamonds which kind of toothpaste is
it um it's like charcoal toothpaste oh
you gotta use the charcoal chocolate
toothpaste with like a powder
um
crazy [ __ ] too much so you're going just
you're just going You're Gonna you're
gonna get you're gonna get the set the
pearlies the pearly whites what was the
reasoning behind that was it just I mean
you told me why so tell everybody why
just trying to elevate yeah I mean
Elevate everything that I'm doing um
I don't know yeah Elevate everything
that I'm doing and just
like because I'm trying to get into the
like you know the acting and then you
know now I'm doing like VMAs and fashion
shows and and and just things of that
nature covers and all type of [ __ ] like
that so it's like you feel like having
the diamond teeth people already kind of
make their mind up about you yeah they
got kind of make it their mind up about
you and you could cover up tattoos for
this smile you can't take this [ __ ] off
which is crazy yeah
you gotta stick you gotta carry the
little little picks with you everywhere
you go yeah I mean you were just taking
down Skittles and I was like yo yeah
with your teeth is that like a yeah I
got my flaws that's like a difficult eat
I feel like it is I ain't eating [ __ ]
though I [ __ ] love Raising Cane so
I'm gonna go get me some Raising Canes
they just opened one five minutes away
yeah it's [ __ ] crazy okay Raising
Cane's I looked it up what is your go-to
cause I get what's that chicken sandwich
you get the sandwich yeah I get the
sandwich bro originally yeah that bread
is good bro
what that bread good bro you gotta get
the Caniac you get six pieces of chicken
no coleslaw double toast oh that sounds
good then you make your own sandwich out
of the toast damn
you get six pieces of chicken and I can
make my own sandwich yeah
Caniac it is six pieces you get double
toast no coleslaw because that goes
leave here I'm I'm going to get a candy
yet
I I mean for me it's that sauce in that
Texas toast that Raising Cane's yeah
you should get a endorsement they're
giving I mean Iced Teas endorsements
from what I understand Wiz Khalifa is a
[ __ ] investor snoopers call me
do they got Raising Canes in uh they
don't but I'll [ __ ] promote the hell
out of beer
what do they got is it uh what's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] Bojangles no there's a
gacks but yeah exactly Zaxby's Zaxby's I
don't [ __ ] know you know what I'm
talking about yeah they say it's like a
it's like Raising Canes but not as good
not as good not as good hell no you're a
Caniac you're a cane fan yeah
um all right man so EP officially
so yeah Boys Don't Cry it's coming out
of the seventh of October October
October 7th we get the EP album by the
end of the year it's your first album
first ever it's crazy to think that this
is like technically your first album I
mean it's not that crazy because I'm
like I'm more so the artist that's under
the radar bro like you are for sure yeah
like so like a lot of I just I let
everybody do what they do because like
my thing is bro I wanted I wanted to
take all the proper steps and being that
I wanted to take all about the fan base
now yeah being that I wanted to take all
the proper steps on
it's like yo like like this [ __ ] got to
be done the right way
big features for the album yeah big
features I ain't even want to do no
features but but you did them because
they made sense yeah female feature mail
feature both both
I wouldn't mind hearing you LMA he said
you said you want my hearing me with
Janae no LMA or Janae Janae maybe too oh
either one hmm are you trying to say
janae's on the album I didn't say that I
feel like it did
you got a pregnant Janae verse or prior
to the pregnancy verse which one was it
that is good bro [ __ ]
that's going to be amazing you said it
man yeah you said it wow you said it I
want to know what that sounds like
I don't know what it sounds like too you
know what it sounds like cause you got
it in your phone
you said I got a drake feature too I
mean I feel like you're the kind of
artist that Drake would just you would
just wake up on like a Saturday yeah a
drink would just hop on your [ __ ] yeah
I mean a lot of people's confused like I
remember when you first came out the
Tuesday slide was going on but you know
yeah a lot of people because that was me
everybody thought it was you yeah no
hell no but you know I want a lot of old
bro the lover the you know the lover
boys don't usually connect the lover
boys like think about it like the other
boys he's a lover boy and lover boy and
I'm nowhere close to Drake like if Drake
who else is a lover boy you Drake you
got like the the Brent fires breakfast
is fire yeah he toxic though he's his
album is [ __ ] up that's what they say
about him they say he toxic I ain't
really toxic I'm a good guy
would we consider Tori a lover boy yeah
he's definitely a fighter boy
shout out to August downstairs
definitely a lover boy oh you got a few
bro
hey Tori's new album is hard I play I
heard that she said a rod to be a lover
boy Rod wave Rod's crazy yeah yeah you
and Rod ever uh connect
so he'll be on the new album too so
Broadway will be on it
you know what's great upgraded body
language the when I when I asked that
question and you said nothing how do you
know is that though it's Broadway's on
the album so janaiko you heard it here
first exclusive the album's coming out
top of the year yeah we gonna piss my
fans off they're gonna [ __ ]
attractless gonna come out just like
this Rod wave Janae and and we're
putting it into the air we're gonna
attract the Drake feature no
no we'll see if it happens yeah you
think you're better at basketball than
Drake
Drake I don't want no problems I just
want a song bro make a [ __ ] record
happen I just want a song bro uh Drake
he's got the owl chain already
come on what are we doing Drizzy Drizzy
owes me fifty thousand dollars by the
way no way I swear to God
we made a bet
why would he say this on my episode I
already said it on Drake
Drake you owe me 50K you remember you
remember bro Sun Sons made it to the
final show me 50 000 anyway listen
um are you are we pushing a single right
now
Which single are we playing on the radio
between love is and heartaches love love
is is already at radio right now that
was my that was my highest streaming
debut song wow yeah and they said you
fell off crazy right I don't know who
because I haven't seen that but
maybe I see the comments more than other
people I mean it's about you you know
what it is dude is like people who
comment that kind of [ __ ] are losers
yeah if you go out they got like seven
followers that's the thing I always say
this to people I'm like look the people
who take their energy their time no
matter how little it is to put
negativity in the world about somebody
that they don't know that's a special
kind of [ __ ] boy that's some loser [ __ ]
or it's like yo those are the people you
don't got to worry about worry about the
people who are giving you love bro worry
about people are paying for tickets to
see you live those are real people [ __ ]
the internet these [ __ ] are
weenies
brosy appreciate you always brother that
was fun my God boom